[Música]
y
de mí
[Música]
son solo siete notas
y hay una diversidad increíble de música
ahora bien
si la música es diversa
como no va a ser diversa
la humanidad que la construye
con estas
palabras transformadas en frase
es que los invito a conocer el arte de
las musas
el arte
una acción inexplicable
intransferible nace del interior mismo
del ser humano
es un acto enigmático mágico
que trasciende las barreras mortales
deleitándonos
más allá del espacio y el tiempo
es interesante saber que el ser humano
encontró la forma de viajar en el tiempo
del presente al pasado
del pasado al futuro
un ejemplo de esto son las cuevas de
altamira donde están rubricadas nuestras
manos
eternizadas en piedra
a través de los siglos
y digo esto porque cuando terminó una
obra
y ni hablar cuando la veo en papel en
ejecución se ponen en marcha
los más misteriosos engranajes
de la máquina del tiempo que jamás
hayamos imaginado
les cuento algo lo busquemos más el arte
en la máquina del tiempo
somos somos seres expresivos
el ser humano está en constante
comunicación
aun cuando no lo desea también lo está
como expresivos
nuestras expresiones y emociones dan
nota
al mundo de que lo que nos pasa
y somos enigmáticos
porque desde esa
misma
enigmas ya
es que intentamos encontrar
ese sentido esta respuesta
convirtiéndonos todos
en filósofos
es interesante
saber
que el arte encuentra la forma de tras
andar
y el don
el don
bueno yo me enseñó música en papá
un poco a decir verdad a cuando era
chica
y él me decía yo te puedo enseñar música
pero no el don
porque el don es inexplicable
pero a lo largo del tiempo que
transcurrirá mi vida me he dado cuenta
que el don lo tenemos todos
cada cual
para una cosa determinada y es imposible
que usted le transfiera el don a ella o
que vos lo transfiera a ella es
imposible
e intentar explicar lo menos
recuerdo
cuando estrené música el año pasado en
nueva york
en una iglesia muy hermosa de la isla de
manhattan un patrimonio cultural de la
ciudad de mediados del siglo 19
la problemática del idioma hacía que yo
prestara atención a lo que me decían y
al mismo tiempo mientras me hablaban
prestaba atención a cómo les voy a
explicar todo lo que tengo en la cabeza
y cómo va a salir todo esto
pero antes de eso
acá en argentina
un intercambio de e-mails los centenares
no sé cuántos no los contemos con nick
johnson
arreglador bibliotecario y músico de la
cuba orquesta que es una orquesta de gtb
muy importante de manhattan
en esos mails había
dos idiomas
uno con dificultad el otro
sin ningún problema ustedes
cual piensan que a cadena le costaba y
cual piensan que no había necesidad de
explicarlo
la música
el miércoles anterior al ensayo general
estando allá
me acerco
y bueno cuando llegó a la iglesia entró
por un costado estaban los colegas
armando y sacando sus estuches mostrando
sus instrumentos presentándose en el
escenario un poco lo que hicimos antes
acá
y la artista
me saluda sonriente
y me dice que tenía una duda
entonces una vez que arma el arpa
mejor dicho se funda el arpa la colocan
arma su atril pone la partitura
me dice está bien así y yo le dije
perfecto
eso fue el miércoles el sábado fue el
día en que mi corazón
estuvo atravesado por una cantidad de
mociones increíbles imagínense
estrenando música en otro país con todo
lo que eso implica la movilización
interna que eso representa
por supuesto la obra fue atravesada por
lo que está sin ningún tipo de
inconvenientes
el público conectó hubo muchos aplausos
muchas caricias en el alma
y eso me hizo pensar en algunas cosas
y me doy cuenta
que en realidad hay una sola
arte
y ustedes dirán no pero bueno es el cine
el séptimo arte de galena sí pero creo
que en realidad las artes creo que en
realidad es una en realidad son
distintas aristas no la danza es una
la música es otra el cine el teatro
y profundizando aún más
dije
que una de las maravillas de la música
fue lograr
que trascienda que eternice y como
hacemos eso
escribiendo el sonido
un sonido
tomado y escrito
hay filosófico pero al mismo tiempo es
un hecho real las partituras son sonidos
escritos
y hasta su duración
pero seguir pensando y dije
y se habló de sonido qué es
y el sonido del ruido
es ruido
que se le enseñó a hablar
entonces el ruido se le enseña a hablar
se transforma en sonido el sonido
logramos escribirlo y logramos aterrizar
eternizarlo y así de esa forma
perdura en el tiempo
hace poco tuve una entrevista para un
medio interesante de alcance nacional
y yo decía que el arte es algo más que
la carrera del éxito en la vida de un
artista
es tratar de poder contar la mayor
cantidad de historias posibles
trata de hacérsela llegar porque el
ciclo de la composición termina cuando
alguien escucha
a veces me sucede en los conciertos
que está a la luz de escenario nada más
y junto con mis colegas algo como lo que
vieron recién
entonces
una intenta proyectar a ver un poco
no puede ver lo siento a cada uno de
ustedes no sé cómo tiene que ver con
esto
esta cosa enigmática
y a veces veo algún rostro que está como
en segundo plano
como cuando alguien le estás hablando y
esa persona te está mirando pero vos no
estás que no está prestando atención
bueno eso me pasa a mí cuando yo estoy
ahí
y alguna persona no está prestando
atención a lo que está sucediendo en ese
instrumento y en mis colegas
y me preguntó
acaso piensa usted
que soy una persona transexual
acaso intenta por sus preconceptos su
cultura instalada de forma inconsciente
lógico encasillarme
la pongo acá la pongo acá donde la pongo
dos cosas se hicieron que yo no me
detenga en eso la vida misma
y mi psicóloga
entonces no me detengo a pensar yo sigo
tocando con mis colegas disfruto
pasa una pieza pasa el 2 vuelvo a mirar
lo señaló ahí porque es la última
espacio y estaba antes estaba sentada y
lo vuelvo a mirar en un señor y termino
una pieza y aplaudía me miraba un cuerpo
que sube y me dice que bueno galena te
pasaste la app
de esa mirada del rictus intentando
descifrar y aparte chocando con ese
preconcepto
a conectar directamente entonces el arte
cuanto cuenta de mí
todo
el arte atraviesa fronteras sociales y
lo que acabo de contar qué es
por supuesto que atraviesa fronteras
sociales
miren tengo dos frases citas que creo
que sintetizan esto si me permiten
estamos bien de tiempo el arte
testimonia
lo que no dijimos
lo que no les quiero decir y muy
probablemente
lo que nunca quiera decir
lo dice el de todas formas
mi amigo el piano la música es mucho más
que sonidos no lo dijimos antes es el
ruido que emprendió el camino de la wta
aprendió a hablar
voy 15 minutos y no hay por supuesto hay
un montón de gente que con temas super
interesantes para hablar así que me debo
a una conclusión
y cuando me dijeron que tenía que hacer
una conclusión de que yo no hay
conclusión cuando se trata de arte
no hay conclusión cuando está en marcha
la imaginación
voz se imagina durante 30 segundos listo
no
no existen medidas de tiempo
no existe
el encasillamiento
el arte
es ese big band que nos puso en marcha
minúsculo pero inmensamente importante
nuestro big band
el interrogante la respuesta otra vez el
interrogante otra vez la respuesta y nos
impulsa hacia adelante y nos impulsa
es decir qué conclusión chicos y chicas
chicas no hay
qué le parece
si cerramos
como empezamos
pero entendiendo un poquito más de qué
se trata todo esto lo decimos bien
fuerte las notas musicales
empezamos 2
re mi fa sol la sí sí sí sí sí sí
son siete y los mitos
se cansaron de hacer música
no te gustan los beatles beethoven al no
escuchar música clásica los rollings
cullen a
los otros chicos que van a tocar acá
si con sólo siete notas
hay infinidad de música
como no va a ser diversa
esta humanidad que lo construye les
agradezco mucho muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]